[Music]
the loud house is jam-packed with loads
of crazy moments some of which even
surprised us from time to time watch
until the end to find out which loud
house moments shocked fans out of their
seats you won't believe what Lincoln's
got himself into this time first time at
the things don't forget to hit that
subscribe button and give this video a
big thumbs up now let's jump right into
the loud houses craziest moments April
Fool's
luan goes berserk there's nothing like
pranking your siblings which is why
April Fool's Day can sometimes get out
of hand in a big household well the loud
family is no exception to the rules and
this is something we clearly saw
displayed in the April Fool's Rules
episode luan might be on the Commerce
side but this episode brought out her
true colors so much so that the rest of
the family couldn't deal so what was so
crazy about this episode well the short
answer is everything from the get-go
Lincoln shows us just how far luan went
to prank her siblings and while she had
a good thing going for a while the Louds
ended up retaliating to put an end to
her madness the Louds conspired against
her and struck when nighttime was in
full bloom they quietly crowded her bed
and pounced on poor luan flash-forward
to the next scene and luan was behind
bars for her crimes despite pleading to
be released the Louds didn't show her an
ounce of mercy
so basically louia got a taste of her
own medicine after a few short hours
luan began to crack and her mental state
took a direct hit after a series of
horrible jokes the confinement got the
best of her and she escaped this crazy
loud house moment did not go unnoticed
especially since luan went on to
traumatize her siblings like never
before so when it comes to pranks luan
is not to be underestimated but then
again if you're going to trap someone in
a cage you shouldn't expect to get away
with it the security crackdown there's
no use in denying it lisa is just one of
the weirdest Louds alive but we love her
just the same she might be the second
youngest loud member but she's one of
the smartest this was clearly showcased
in the lock and loud episode which
placed the loud family at the center of
a make-believe home in
Bayesian after coming back from dancing
lessons Lin senior school did his
children over not locking the front door
which caused a series of unfortunate
events to take place taking his words to
heart the loud family became obsessed
with securing the perimeter of their
home so much so that Rita and Flynn
senior started having issues with
walking through their own front door
throughout this episode we get to see
just how deranged
little Lisa really is for starters she
admits to having a secret camera in the
bathroom which is more than a little
invasive secondly she starts asking her
family members for stool samples however
she gives little explanation about what
she's going to do with them
the Louds commitment with keeping their
house safe quickly becomes dangerous but
it's Lisa's attitude that takes first
place while she might be young and quiet
Lisa is up to something that most of us
want to know nothing about but clearly
she has some sort of strange obsession
with feces now if that's not crazy
we don't know what is alright hops keep
an eye on them until we get back
good girl Lana kids do crazy things but
some of them manage to make adult
questions their sanity while it's normal
for children to pretend to be animals
when they're young Lana loud takes
pretending to a whole new level
the young loud member wants nothing more
than to play in the mud
but unfortunately this is something that
many people frown down upon Lola and
Lana might be twins but the two girls
couldn't be any more different well it's
obvious that Lola is a beauty queen it's
equally as evident that Lana is a tomboy
and while there's nothing wrong with
that there is something wrong about
playing in the mud when it's raining
cats and dogs outside because let's face
it that's a surefire way to catch a cold
order an infection after watching dogs
play in the mud through the window we
see Lana's eyes go wide with envy she
then takes off running to the front door
like a mutt but is stopped by her twin
sister Lola yells Lana heel and points
towards her dog bed which she then runs
to this shocking scene made most of us
laugh out loud and it's only normal
after all we're seeing a young girl act
like a dog and her sister treating her
like one all in all
Lana takes acting like a dog to a
whole new level so much so that were
almost convinced she's part Labrador
pudding Lily down for a nap
when Lincoln woke up on a sunny Sunday
morning the last thing he expected was
to get rushed to his aunt Ruth's house
so he did what any 11-year old would he
convinced his mom to let him stay at
home but his freedom did come at a price
and at the time it seemed like something
he could afford
Lincoln was given the task of
babysitting his 15 month old sister Lily
which he thought would be a breeze well
unfortunately for Lincoln he soon found
out that taking care of a toddler was a
full-time job wanting some extra help
Lincoln invited Clyde over and the two
boys desperately tried to take care of
Lily two boys and a baby is a crazy
episode for more than one reason for
starters Rita allowed her
eleven-year-old son to stay home alone
with her toddler which isn't exactly
good parenting secondly the boys had no
idea how to take care of a baby which
put little Lily in imminent danger if
there's one scene that took things over
the top it's when Lincoln and Clyde
started to blast white noise on dozens
of stereos to get Lily to bed which is
more than a little traumatizing for a
baby
luckily cartoons are not based on
real-life events
or at least we hope they aren't in touch
oven
anyone who has siblings of their own
knows just how fun it is to mess with
them however some pranks can be taken a
little too far after being forced to
share a bed with his sister Lynne
Lincoln was soon subjected to one of the
nastiest nights he ever would encounter
but he did manage to hold his ground
after pretending to go to sleep Lynne
waited for the perfect moment to pounce
and did she ever within seconds she
trapped her only brother in a Dutch oven
not familiar with this term well you
soon will be a Dutch oven is what occurs
after someone farts under the covers and
getting trapped in one is a feat we
wouldn't wish upon our worst enemies in
this episode Lynne lets a loud one rib
and then throws the covers over
Lincoln's head he desperately tries to
squirm his way out of it but Lynne
manages to outmaneuver him this crazy
moment makes us feel sorry for Lincoln
but he soon gets his revenge
he waits for her to fall asleep and then
gets even and she soon finds out how it
feels to have to breathe in someone
else's stench this insane loud house
moment isn't easily forgotten which is
why we're still talking about it today
you've got this girl there are tons of
crazy moments in the patching things up
episode but there's one that stood out
to us the most in this episode Lola and
Lana end up going to camp Bluebell where
they're made to pass a series of tests
but being extremely different people
Lola and Lana end up getting into a
number of fights while their issues
might get resolved by the end of the
episode a lot of questionable moments do
arise being the tomboy that she is Lana
aces nearly every single Bluebell task
that comes her way but the same can't be
said about Lola so when Lola is given at
a she believes to be too difficult
her sister gives her a big smack on the
butt and says you got this girl this
unexpected moment leaves Lola yelping
out loud but the action is immediately
dismissed tons of fans couldn't help but
laugh about this crazy loud house moment
in truth you never know what the lads
are about to do and this scene was
definitely unexpected if I'm home by
five they'll never have to know who
wants to go to the mall the loud parents
get busted all redownland senior one is
to spend some quality time together
however there are 11 kids don't want to
be left alone so when the loud parents
plan for a weekend getaway at a hotel
they begged them to tag along unable to
refuse their pleas Frida and Lynn senior
obliged by the end of the weekend the
Louds end up getting kicked out of the
hotel but this punishment has nothing to
do with the actions of the loud children
believe it or not but their parents got
kicked out for skinny-dipping in the
hotel pool after hours this scene is
somewhat subtle but we later find out
exactly what they're doing instead of
telling their kids the real reason why
they got thrown out of the hotel they
choose to tell them a little lie this
leads them to feel horrible which
prompts them to sleep at their aunt
Ruth's house for the remainder of the
weekend
their absence gives Rita and Lynn's
senior all the alone time they could
have ever asked for this crazy loud
house moment left many of us shocked but
hey parents deserve to have a little fun
every once in a while - right
Lily sees stars Lily might be the
youngest loud member but what she lacks
in age she makes up in feistiness being
the only boy out of eleven children can
have its challenges which is why Lincoln
attempts to brainwash Lily into liking
the same things he does despite not
having a lot in common with his older
siblings Lincoln is confident that he
can get little Lily to become just like
him so he attempts to make her fall in
love with isapi which is his favorite
crime fighter to start her off strong he
tapes pictures of a savvy to Lily's baby
mobile and start spinning it at an
alarming rate he forces her to stare at
the images as they go round and round
which proves to be a bad idea within
seconds Lily's eyes begin to twirl and
she groggily walks towards Lincoln she
then collapses into his arms and vomits
all over his a savvy comic book this
crazy loud house moment goes to show
that you can't force someone to like the
same things you do sorry Lincoln but it
looks like you're on your own Lynne on
the field back in the day kids used to
spend the majority of their time outside
but today they'd much rather play video
games or watch TV
Lincoln is no exception to the rule
which is why his parents forced him to
play football in the loudest yard
episode well it turns out that Lincoln
is 100% terrified of playing football
which prompted him to convince Lynne to
take his place on the field although she
may be a girl Lynn's appearance was
easily concealed by wearing Lincoln's
helmet so the two siblings traded places
things were going according to plan
until Lin started excelling and making
headlines proud of his son Lynne senior
got the entire family to agree to watch
Lincoln's next game this crazy and
action-packed episode left most of us on
the edge of our seats and as we feared
things didn't work out too well for
Lincoln by the end of the episode it
turns out that getting someone else to
walk in your shoes isn't always the best
idea but unfortunately Lincoln had to
learn this the hard way despite being a
girl Lynne managed to be all the boys on
Lincoln's team and we can't say that
we're surprised I were going to do a
text how would I go about that Bobby's
going down it's only normal for siblings
to want to protect each other which is
why many of us didn't bat an eye when
Lincoln started spying on Bobby in
cheater by the Dozen this episode is
filled with crazy moments some of which
children couldn't begin to understand by
now we all know that Lincoln doesn't
like to follow the rules which is why we
weren't surprised to see him stalking
Bobby after noticing some suspicious
behavior Lincoln convinces his siblings
except for Laurie that Bobby is cheating
the loud siblings go on to spend the
rest of the day chasing after Bobby and
they find some pretty troubling stuff
for starters Bobby takes an unknown girl
to makeout hill and then he sneaks into
Laurie's neighbor's house and takes off
his pants lastly he goes to some
underground club and slow dances with a
man this crazy episode leads us to
believe that Bobby is a no-good cheater
but it also shows us just how far
Lincoln will go to protect his sisters
so which loud house moment did you find
the craziest let us know in the comments
below and that's the end of our video
thanks for watching and see you next
time
[Music]